Hey guys, Kumi here wants to say something for all of us.
You still don't believe me?
We're actually live, you bitch!
You can't pull the same shit on me three times.
We're actually live!
Finally, I tried to pretend to be going live two times
before.
Hold on.
And she didn't believe me.
And now that we're actually live, She's nasty.
Please!
Give me my baby, please!
Holy shit.
I fucking muted you instantly.
Hey, you told me to bake.
You told me.
You told me to bake.
Bro!
That's...
Bro, that's a little bit too much.
Hey!
I told you to warn your sound guy.
Oh my god!
That was...
Sorry.
I did not realize I had to turn that way down.
No, you told me to beg, and I said I was gonna put my
begging pants on.
You were like, okay, I'm like, okay, tell your sound guy.
And you're like, why?
I told you.
Oh my God.
I'm so sorry, everybody.
I did not realize how loud that loud was going to be.
And it was, it was like, this guy really, Gumi really wants
to be mod.
So I was like, just beg for it.
I was like, but I was like, not right now, though.
Do it while we're streaming.
Do it.
It's for the whole world to see.
I am so sorry for everybody that went down there.
Hey, sound dude.
What's up?
All right, guys.
Today's the day.
I can finally finalize this divorce and leave my bitch of a
while.
I I get to leave my stupid asshole my husband.
There's completely nothing in this house.
Wow I don't need your money You marry me to be a trophy
husband.
I well, you sure ain't a trophy.
I'll tell you that much I know for sure that I'm a catch.
I'm a fucking catch You did you did what you married me?
Why would you marry a fucking farmer as an engineer?
Go in?
into the plant!
Sometimes people lie.
Oh, for like 10 plus years?
Like, that child is, like, at least 10.
Go in!
I don't want that.
Okay, and we, this fucking stream will never end.
Wait, I got a cool little tag.
Okay.
Good.
Sorry, I my hand slipped.
We did it!
Look at that!
Oh my god!
Wow, you're so smart!
How did you know we had to do that?
You say something?
You have to do this thing over there.
You say something freak boy?
This is no not fair.
Why do you get to be DPS?
I'm like the support.
I'm the husband.
Oh, that's better.
Why do you get to be DPS?
Teya!
No.
Wait, what does that even do?
What does the water do?
To me, please.
Please for the long...
Maybe you should touch up those dandelion sprouts.
Oh, you have to water the plants!
That was fast.
Go water the plants.
What plants?
In the fucking planter.
Where do you think- I already watered them!
You just jump right into the pot.
Be one with your garden.
Yeah, see, you didn't fucking water them before.
They've been watered!
Wait, how do I?
You're looking me go.
Yay!
God.
I have to do all the work here.
Don't be.
Wait, what?
You have to do this.
What the?
What?
Oh, there it is.
Here you go.
I did it.
You're fucking welcome.
Look at me go.
Ah!
say hydrated even if you're getting a divorce remember to
stay hydrated don't make me put on my begging pants again
down guy what happened to my greenhouse it looks terrible
yeah that is what happens when you abandon your passion it
gets infected infected stuff is everywhere and it will get
infected or a fuck infected my garden no may let's take this
purple stuff out what the fuck why do i have to deal with it
because you're the wife also get this way give me a sec i
just need to make sure the sound is okay after i fucking had
the swap all right here we go we're good no no no no don't
believe her lies don't believe her lies Do not believe her
lies.
She's gonna go so loud later.
Don't believe her lies.
Oh, I got the DPS!
Look at that.
You wish you could do that.
Oh, it's we guys going for zombies!
She's lying.
She's the one that tempted me to marry her with that voice
and then look at her now.
Look at her now.
They all change.
Can you like help me kill these guys like what do you think
I'm doing?
Okay, good job What the fuck?
Well, that'll teach him to stay away from my guard.
Don't believe her lies.
Don't believe it!
It's a honey pie!
Don't believe her!
She's gonna take all your money like she took mine.
I didn't sign the freedom.
I'm gonna make money, doggie?
Wait, which way?
Bro, these?
What the fuck?
How do I...
Oh!
Oh, I gave you like a platform!
Is it here?
Come over here.
There you go.
What are you doing?
And then...
There you go.
I don't think this is where we go.
I think this is as far as I can stretch.
Is that way?
Getting a salad on looking over there?
Guys, I...
Guys, I think I went the wrong way.
I don't know how I went the wrong way.
Guys, there is a possibility that I went the wrong way.
I don't know how.
But I think...
You're making these leaves so far.
What do you mean?
They're, like, perfectly...
Whoa, whoa.
How do I fucking...
Get to you?
No more!
That's the furthest I can get to.
Oh, I can...
Hey, you know the piss flower?
The what flower?
The piss flower?
No, I do not.
No, not guys.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, I'm so thirsty.
Oh, you have to...
Oh, you're like watered and...
As you got a watered and a pad, it's the only way!
I could have fucking died.
Yeah, yeah.
Okay, now you have to go through the window.
Okay.
now I go through the window look at me go here I am now you
have to die you have to die no you have to die and go
through the window I don't have to die look no no no you
make a leave you make a leave there I can't get there what
do you mean you go to the window you go straight through the
window you go straight through the window and then what huh
and then what make a leave
I forgot I could do that.
Oh my god, you're so smart.
This is why we got married in the first place.
You just...
You knew the answers that I don't.
Alright, water this plant.
Yay!
Where do I go?
I need to reconnect the fish.
You gotta reconnect the what?
The fish.
The fish?
What the fuck is the fish?
We just have to chop it all up, right?
Oh, I hope it's that simple.
Okay.
I'm growing the leaves.
Here you go.
Is that much better, my queen?
Is that a better leaf grow for you, queen?
Yeah, that's good enough.
You're so demanding.
Oh, guys, I'm...
Volume check.
Fuck off.
Oh, wow.
What's this?
Okay, here you go.
How do I do I do this again?
I don't remember.
I'll pull it.
Pull.
And then...
Open up.
Oh my god!
In front of me?
You're gonna do that in front of me?
I knew it.
Dude, you want me to let him fucking die?
Wait, am I a cuck?
Did you hear that?
Yes.
What the fuck?
Yes, what was it?
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
Oh, that's not a ball.
Oh, that is not a... Yeah.
Oh, wait.
How do I fucking contribute?
Fucking...
Oh, oh, like this!
I'm holding on!
Water it, water it!
Oh, okay, never mind.
I guess you have to beat him up.
Do something!
I can't attack!
Oh, my god!
There's a
creeps on me!
What can I do?
I literally can't.
I can't do anything!
Oh, I can attack.
By the way, I can also attack.
If you also want to know.
I held it!
I held it with my fucking life.
Mine grows up.
Ow!
Oh, okay.
That's on you.
I held it.
Oh, okay.
Um, um, um, um, um, just dodge.
Why can't you jump?
I just dodged.
I'm melee, man.
There you go.
Look, I held him.
I'm holding him by the neck.
I'm watching all happen in front of me.
See, look at that.
I dodged.
It's just that easy.
Just move to the left and the right.
Damn, we barked things.
We did it!
We whipped them into shape, didn't we?
Where'd we go now?
Oh, okay.
Good one.
Bro, I don't know how to tend a garden, apparently.
Yeah.
Skirt and fucking sucks.
I don't know.
Raising our daughter because somebody else wouldn't.
She's at school.
She's literally 10 years old.
She's literally at home right now.
It's the weekend.
Oh, now you fucking realize what day it is.
Wow.
I can't believe it.
You don't even care.
You come home late at night at like 9 p.m.
Every fucking day.
Well, I have to raise our daughter.
raise what jeremy who's jeremy jeremy um your boss no no i
didn't know i have to get a raise somehow is this is this
why you came home with a new car that night i thought you
got a promotion i did get a promotion and a new car what did
you do for that promotion you know I I just wanted to oh boy
oh boy oh boy everything's infected there's still time I
need to run kill the infection and make your garden bloom
again Sometimes, okay, I feel like this game is giving the
wrong message because it's teaching people that like you can
like you can fix a marriage Even if they want to get a
divorce, but just let people get a divorce like what the
fuck?
It should be normalized.
I kind of understand it because there is a kid involved in
everything But like if the marriage is already sort of like
that bad like I feel like if you're to the point where
you're like this close to getting divorced I don't think you
should force yourself to like make it work oh hey here it is
jump further than me that's easy all right here we go how do
i wee wee dude i used to be so scared of this shit
what the fuck oh yes what the hell i was more patient than
you for once in my life you a champion wait is that how
momentum works because i thought if you go all the way up
yeah but i didn't go all the way like around so like i had
more momentum going off because i i got off it looked like
it was all the way at the top yeah i had like i didn't do it
when i was like all the way up to the top
Like someone super chatted like that's what you get for
marrying A woman with the name ho at the end
Wait, what are you doing?
Is that racially motivated?
What do you what do you want to know?
I'm a goofy ho Is that racially motivated?
It's a Korean word.
Is that racially motivated?
Who's saying that?
Who's disrespecting it?
Wow!
Anyway, I'm having a great time playing this game Anyway,
this game has been really fun so far.
Whoa!
I'm having so much fun.
I'll turn this around anyway.
Water the fucking planet.
I'll turn this shit around.
Whoa!
Okay, I'm gonna jump on.
Hi, guys.
Welcome to It Takes Two, where we're having a great time.
This game is so fun.
Whoa!
Oh my god, playing with a good friend here.
Woo, that thing, controversial.
Oh, so we're friends.
Oh, okay.
What does this dragonfly do?
Was he just...
He's just staring at us.
Oh, what the fuck?
Look at the graphics, man.
It's so good.
I know if you...
Oh my god.
No wonder this game won Game of the Year, I think.
Did this game win...
Did this game win Game of the Year?
What are you doing?
Wait, I need to drink water for this.
Okay, help me now.
Dude, this reminds me of those carnival games.
Oh, yeah, like the clown.
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's a little spider!
What?
Oh, no.
It's a- wait, what the fuck?
That is not a- that's a sm- that is not a- that can't be a
spider.
That's a spider?
That's like a tree!
Okay, I've got- they go me.
Ignore him!
Think about the big guy!
Just run past him!
I can't!
It makes me auto-lock him!
Just fucking look past him!
There you go, I did it.
Okay, it's fine.
I'll help you.
See, don't forget who helped you.
Watch out, babe.
More creatures.
Oh, shit.
There you go.
I did it.
I pulled him.
Ignore the others.
They don't matter.
They're just babies.
Okay.
I'm holding on him.
Ignore the others.
What are you going to do?
Kill you?
I like how I don't know.
Look at my health pool.
You're literally full HP.
you're fine see it look they're little babies it's like
squishing snails which i would never do i would never i
would never do i have never done whatsoever in my life i
just i just tell other people to do it for me okay what the
like ever been to a very humid place and then like after it
rains or it's raining and all the snails come out yeah yeah
it's not it's like they're everywhere you can't just like
not they're just in your way you know like you can just
accidentally step on them it's not like i did it on purpose
and then because like the whole walkway because i have to go
to school the whole walkway is like Somebody to, like, make
a path for me.
Oh, he's such a cute spider.
A ride to the other side.
I hope it eats.
All right.
Okay, thank you.
No, that somebody was my dad.
He would, like, make a pathway for me to walk through
because the whole pathway was filled with snails.
But then you can hear the audible crunch, too.
No!
What about you?
We'll find another one.
Come on.
You need a win.
Yay!
Wait, what do I do?
What do I do?
Why do you left?
What?
That's what the web was for!
Hello?
Are you going to do anything?
I don't know how to use it.
I mean, you don't know how to use it.
Okay, figure out how to use it before I do anything.
Okay, what are you doing?
What is that?
What are you doing?
I don't know!
Okay, I'm flying!
Oh, are you...
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Do you know what to do now?
Why the fuck does he go hypers?
What the fuck?
Wait, what's going on?
Okay.
Oh!
Nice.
Just keep filling it.
Alright, we're good.
I'm out.
I'm on the other side.
You can come back now.
I miss going hiking in the forest.
Where do we go?
This way.
Why don't you go?
Hypers!
No?
I found more.
Oh, it's another spider for me?
It's for me!
Oh yeah!
We get to ride our spiders together.
Come on, spider, you're free to go.
Oh my god, they're a couple!
Get divorced now before she takes everything.
Oh, back that thing up.
Nice!
Do spiders, I thought spiders like, don't have, like,
husband and wives.
The female spider just eats the fucking male spider.
I thought like most insects just like eat the other one
after they after they bang i like how somebody was like
their siblings i mean they're bugs they don't care if
they're sad do they do they care don't like ants like don't
wait how did you do that Why did you do that?
Oh, I forgot how.
Okay, I figured it out.
I forgot the controls all of a sudden.
Where are we going?
Oh.
Wait for me!
I've never had a pet spider.
Wait for me, I'm so fucking far!
Wait, where are you?
Oh my god, you're so ahead.
Hey, Spidey.
You doing alright down there?
Mommy, please.
I'm so behind.
Do me, please.
I was a little slow.
Just for today.
I'll wait for you right here.
Oh, just because you have to.
You're forced to.
Hi, first.
Very strong spider.
How do I get off this?
Oh, I can do it while I'm on the spider.
Oops.
Fill that up.
Glup, glup, glup.
I wish that were me.
Fill that up.
Glup, glup.
What?
Fill that up.
I wish Rose was here to see this.
I don't think Rose would want to.
Let's just give her more trauma, you know?
That's what a kid would want.
More trauma.
Yay!
Where the fuck is the end for this?
Is there an end?
I don't think so.
I think we were supposed to go up top.
Right?
Yeah.
Yeah, we were.
I'm surprised, like, do we even have any friends outside of
just us two?
You asked this last time too.
I don't know.
I'm just assuming, like, wouldn't somebody visit us and be
like, hey guys?
plants are you growing look i need somebody to give me
attention on the left hey i'm giving you context clues you
see that thing what thing that thing right there oh okay i
almost walked the wrong way don't worry i got this boom i
missed but don't worry i didn't miss this time i did
This is our brain on spiders.
Wait, where do we...
Oh, this way.
Yeah, I need you to do something.
You can wash this off.
Oh, my spider disintegrated!
What?
What kind of fucking gunk is this?
got fucking Thanos snapped.
It's pesticides.
Are these pesticides?
There's no way.
Why would I just spray it on a fucking tree?
Like, of all things.
Oh, the gamer...
What the fuck is the gamer gung?
Oh, you're stuck?
How do I save you?
How the fuck...
Oh, here.
Okay.
Please!
Okay, I've got it.
I think you have to jump.
Right?
I can't jump.
Wait, then what do you do?
You jump on this?
Can you jump on that?
Yeah.
And then you...
And then you head over this way.
It's that easy.
Thank you for the ride again, Spider.
Thank you, Spider.
I'm gonna to make sure we don't squish you when we're back
to normal-sized people.
This was me when I was, like, nine.
I used to be, like, I don't know why, but I woke up in the
middle of the night so thirsty for water.
You know how, like, most Asian households have those kettles
full of water?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I, like, used four, three to four cups.
Oh, that's the mama!
Oh, my God!
So they weren't boyfriend-girlfriend.
They were...
chat tell you that?
Yeah, but like, do you really believe 100% what chat tells
you?
If they played the game before, I would hope so.
I told you!
See?
They have no fucking husband!
The spider killed the husband!
Yeah.
I told you!
I didn't get the foreshadowing about what's about to happen.
Well, technically I'm like the house husband, so wouldn't it
be the other?
no that's not fair what the fuck i do so much around who's
gonna fucking do your laundry you don't know how to do your
laundry what the fuck whatever they are we need to take them
out okay here come i got it how did you die you you like
pulled it down right on top of my head whoopsie me how is i
supposed to know that oh sorry i fell okay all right i
pulled him i pulled him down i pulled him down i pulled him
down that works when i accidentally pull okay all right i
pulled him down i pulled him down hurry up i'm gonna take
this okay we're gonna get rid of all these real fast all
right your turn i pulled him down Pulling him down again.
I'm pulling him.
I'm slapping him with my fucking head whip.
There you go.
It was that easy.
Oh, man.
Oh, my God.
Who are these?
Why are they doing here?
I'm pretty sure, like, the book grew these, too.
The plants are way out.
Hold them up, Koji.
Got it.
Oh, God.
Bro.
You know what?
You're wrong.
right for asking a divorce.
You're...
Maybe like a divorce was a good idea.
I have to reload?
I'm a plant!
What am I reloading?
It's part of my body.
It's literally part of my body.
Oh my god, please.
Fucking spray faster.
Are we done?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
What do you mean?
I couldn't go.
I had to watch the plant roll.
Look, my life is clear.
Me first.
What the fuck?
Where do you go from?
Oh, here.
Here.
We have to beat the shit up.
Yeah, beat that plant up.
God.
What?
Whoa!
Yeah, I was gonna say, is this my garden?
Yeah.
What am I doing in this garden?
Anyways, I used like three to four cups, and then I was just
so thirsty that I drank straight from the kettle.
Wait, wouldn't that be, like, extra hot?
Or, like, did you guys keep it?
No, no, no.
We have a lot, a cold one and a hot one.
waste.
You don't have to do Yeah.
Yeah, you don't have to do more dishwashing.
Is that better?
Yeah.
My grandma used to boil water in the morning and put it in a
cold pot.
Yeah, that's smart.
Yeah, why would that be gross if you're all sharing in the
family?
Ew!
Oh, that's a corpse!
No, it's a skin.
You know, like bug shed.
I think it's dead, Cody.
Oh, no, it's dead.
Okay.
It's a corpse.
so noisy no it's like shedding it's shedding its skin it's a
mold but yeah um i got pneumonia you got pneumonia who gave
you pneumonia or something like that i didn't i drink i was
chugging water too much and i don't know why i was so
thirsty but i got sick wait i think like water okay who the
water went down the wrong hole or something i don't think
that's how there's no way you can get pneumonia from just
drinking water.
I think I also just got pneumonia somehow.
There's no way.
Oh, this is like, okay, but what's the worst shit can happen
when we wake him up?
Watch this.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What is wrong?
Did you watch it?
Yeah, but But did you watch it, though?
I need to know if you saw what I did.
Do you want me to show it to you again?
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
They are kind of cute.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Who did you wake up?
What did you fucking?
Why did you do that?
I didn't do nothing.
You know, you could have went up.
Why did you go down?
I didn't want to go to sit with you.
There's up!
I feel like we're invading that privacy.
Agreed.
Let's get out of here, ASAP.
Oh my god.
Down, isn't like, down harder?
I don't know, I'm already through.
Yeah, because of all the noise you were making, I had to
fucking wait until...
Okay, yeah, you didn't make any noise.
Yeah.
Oh, hey, look at all these...
Oh my god, these ants are so small.
Why do you have so much like motor oil over here?
I've seen like 50 jugs already.
Motor oil, where's the motor oil?
Oh my god, what am I doing well this?
No, that's a wood sealer.
No, to the left.
That's one bucket of motor oil.
One bucket of motor oil is not that many.
You don't see more.
It's okay, Gumi.
I know you don't know much about cars, but...
But that...
Am I fucking weed now?
Look at you.
You look so soft.
Oh, you go.
Are you going?
Where are you going?
Why are you not following me?
I am.
You're just going too fast.
I hear you.
You ready?
Come on.
I'm going.
Oh my god.
I am going as slow as I possibly.
Why are you crouching?
Just fucking run.
That makes me crouch!
It's automatically making me crouch!
That sounds like a skill issue right there.
No one's forcing you to crouch.
Keep moving and deal with it.
Yeah, deal with it.
Oh, stop, stop!
Oh shit, that's a big boy.
Stop, stop!
Whoa!
I see you fucking jump up there because you don't trust me.
You don't fucking trust me.
I can't believe.
What the f- that was you.
That was you.
I was like perfectly in a quiet area.
I know you were gonna move.
You're right.
I don't trust you.
See, you don't even trust your own husband.
You'll need me.
I'm just gonna leave.
look at these these are my new friends the most oh my god do
you see that see what oh my god what the fuck that's so
creepy holy shit wait grab onto that yeah land on me
i can't believe you wouldn't trust me i don't know why Five,
four, three, two, one.
Okay, I'm switching it.
Hi, everyone.
What, and I did swap, what do you mean?
I did swap.
Wait, that one, look at that one.
Oh my God, it's an albino.
That's another.
What the fuck?
Why would you move?
It's albino.
Where is it gonna do breathe on you?
Why are you so paranoid?
Why are you so many?
Because they like to bang!
Oh, yeah, just feel...
Yeah, sorry for this one guy that just likes to fucking do
his shit.
They're rodents!
Have you heard about that?
Have you ever... Do you know about this mouse?
That, like, there's a type of mouse species for the guy
whose whole purpose is to just, like, fuck until it dies
from a heart attack.
Wait, you never...
Okay, there's a... I saw this on National Geographic.
I...
But they're talking about this rat, this rat species that
was literally just banged until it gets a heart attack.
It dies.
It's educational.
No, that's not all mice.
Some mice have her strength and know when to stop.
There's this particular species.
There's a particular species that doesn't know how to stop
for the guys.
And they just do it until they...
get a heart attack i think i think we have to run oh it's
crash baton time it's educational i'm how did you die no i
can just let you do all of this how did you die because i'm
here to let you do everything oh no no i actually have to
play the game
Ow.
See?
What?
Why do you keep jumping?
No!
It forces you to play!
I'm not even pressing anything and it forces you to play!
That's so fucked up.
I can't believe it.
It's not a choice.
It's okay.
Why is your way faster?
It's not fair.
Oh!
Don't worry.
We're gaming.
I'm ahead.
What have we ever done to these moles?
Why are these...
Why do they want us to kill us off?
I literally provide them food.
I literally provide them free food with my garden.
It's Roddy!
Did you see him?
No, no, no, that's not my fault.
It's the book's fault.
That's not my fault.
The book caused this.
Oh, man.
I thought he was gonna get us.
Who?
Are you...
Oh.
maybe he wants to say hi oh my god oh my god what the fuck
that poor boy no no oh my god oh my god we're monsters are
we bad people oh oh it's okay he's still breathing he's
still breathing that's not him that's not him good luck i
believe in
you see look not everything is fine oh my god it's just like
uh little nightmares oh my god the gnome what is up with me
and gnomes wait there's a treasure guys we have to go back
here when i'm bigger oh my god i won't need your money
anymore Wait, what?
Goodbye.
There's more?
Holy shit!
What?
What kind of fucking family is?
There has to be incest involved.
Stop fishing!
The toads!
Whoa what?
They can talk?
sign oh great taxi we're going to the greenhouse no we don't
go to a bad neighborhood bad neighborhood crap is destroyed
everything far as we go is the garden fountain how much fees
price up front us we love they eat
where the did i found that god that is disgusting hey hold
it big boy my back me today hey you take the fat one hey
whoa that's my wife sorry uh namaste oh my god namaste whoa
Oh my gosh, where am I though?
Okay, it's more motor oil down there.
No, what do you mean?
That's not that's that's called That's like the woods in
there
Why are they like New York?
Well one of them is French
Oh my god, wait is this It's frog American?
No, that one's French.
Yeah, but he's in America.
There's no way he was...
There's no way this tadpole was born in France.
There's no way.
They do not live long enough to travel from France to
America.
What are you?
I had, like, a war flashback.
Oh, cool.
What happened?
But, uh, thanks for the ride.
Oh, we gotta go from here.
Oh, don't get into the gunk.
You're going to disintegrate.
Oh, what?
Oh, I actually need you for this guy.
Okay, you go to the right, and then it'll push a button.
Yeah, and then I'll push this button, and then you go to
that one.
See teamwork And then you push that Look at that Frogs can
work together Well done Oh my god look a little frog statue
Oh I have a weird obsession with frogs apparently God I'm
perfect No wonder you married this man Did I have like a
weird thing about frauds why because um hey you need to be
here oh sorry i saw i saw a platform right instantly jump we
have to oh what to get off oh got by the way don't open it
while you're under the thing you have to find a way past it
you have to go under that oh don't worry you got this i
believe you anyways um when i was younger you know the
chinese supermarkets that like let you you just order like
fresh fish or some yeah all right get ready okay do i get in
the frog i do yeah yeah keep doing that okay keep going with
your story hold on let me get to the other one um i went
with She ordered a frog and I watched it get skinned right
before my eyes when I was eight years old.
Oh, wait.
Was it an Asian supermarket?
Yeah, that's why I said it.
Yeah.
But yeah, it like picked me up so much to see if you get
skinned.
They get hardcore sometimes.
Nice.
Wait, how do you how do I get you across?
How do I get you across though?
I'm already over.
know how to get you over.
Can you like how are you supposed to come over here?
Oh, I went backwards!
You have to do this.
I jumped the wrong way.
It's okay.
I don't know what to do now.
Gooby, why didn't you say anything?
I wasn't watching your screen.
I was looking at my screen.
No!
Why weren't you waiting?
I timed it.
You don't.
Okay.
That's not me.
I had it perfectly.
I timed it perfectly.
Okay.
I timed it perfectly to your rhythm.
And then suddenly your rhythm stopped.
How is I supposed to know the rhythm will just disappear?
Huh?
I was like, like right now.
Like right now.
I'm shooting it.
Wait, what?
What was I supposed to jump that one?
Okay, here you go.
All right.
See, look at this rhythm that you have established and then
suddenly it's just gone.
Yeah, and then I'm just making sure and then look look I
have to wait an extra like five seconds You can get off now.
That's it?
Okay.
I got you.
How did you get up here?
Nice job.
Oh.
Alright, here you go.
Go beat that shit up.
Like, Peter here.
Oh, maybe they are French-Canadian.
We actually need to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back real quick.
Oh, my God.
Don't say anything weird to my chat.
I'm going to say anything weird.
Anyways, um, chat.
The garden's looking vibrant.
I can tell you guys a story.
We've still got some infection left, though.
Oh, dude.
I love this story.
But I was playing Truth or Dare with another kid back in
elementary school.
Actually, it was a group of four.
I'm not going to say their names.
But there was a kid.
Who, um, they...
I don't know why they decided to tell us this, but we were
like, Okay, truth, what is the, like, grossest thing you've
done?
And then, they were like, oh, I would pee.
So, like, I would...
We had mice in our house, and they were like...
They would, like, pee on their floor.
leap crackers on their floor because you're like oh the mice
are thirsty and they're probably hungry
and then we were like dude that is not normal that's not
normal and they're like oh yeah my my dad yelled at me for
it i'm like yeah i i would think so anyways i told my about
it and she's like goomy i hope you never talk to that kid
ever again.
That's a story that I love telling.
It's like pee-pee for the mice.
Wow.
The flowers are growing again.
Hmm.
My rat's thirsty.
Let me pee on carpet.
Your garden is beautiful, Cody.
Right, Dokey?
Why aren't you talking?
Did you say to my chat?
What?
Did you say something weird to my chat?
No, the plot twist is that funny.
Why are people in my chat being like, Doki, please never
leave us alone with Gumi again?
What did you say to them?
I didn't say anything.
I told them a story from my past.
Bro, okay.
Okay, that explains everything.
Some of the shit that happened to you when you were younger,
I understand why you're like this.
That wasn't me!
Oh my god, no, there was another...
So, do you know what, that same truth or dare?
Hold on, that same truth or dare?
Oh, there's a game, there's a game!
There's a snail race!
Get over here.
There's a truth or dare?
Um...
We're playing truth or dare and then...
You know how like kids back then were like, I see London, I
see France, I can see your underpants?
Yes.
Um...
Basically...
We were like, we dare you to show your underpants.
And then the kids...
What?
Yeah!
What does that even mean?
What do you mean?
Like, as a what?
Get away from me.
No.
Wait, which one's me?
Oh, that's me.
Okay, I lost track of who I am.
I don't know.
I think you're like, show your underpants.
What?
And then this kid not only...
How old were you guys?
We're like eight!
And you thought that was over.
Okay?
No!
We thought it was embarrassing.
We're like, show you how to pants.
Like, pants yourself.
And then, no, this kid decided to like take off his pants
and his underpants and be on the, like, playground floor in
front of us.
And then we got him.
The Dean, like, a teacher saw it.
And then the Dean got mad.
Of course people, what do you- No, of course!
I know!
We didn't ask him to fucking pee on the floor!
He just did it!
And then the teacher got mad.
Like, I mean, anybody would be mad!
Like, they'd be like, Oh my god!
What is going on?
Anyways!
And- I'll never forgive this bitch.
The other kid who was playing with this, she said it was my
fault.
But I didn't dare him to do that.
Oh
My god, that could have been a fucking lawsuit right there
Oh, I keep the fight he plants watered Red blue blue, okay,
I'm good.
Anyways Mom picked me up.
I'm scared That was the same truth or dare um Game All
right, you made it the same what what did?
What did you tell them earlier?
Kumi, stop cooking.
Turn off the stone.
Thank you for the super chat.
I'm not cooking anything.
I'm just telling childhood stories.
Before I say you're like the creepy uncle.
We're almost there.
Don't you laugh.
That's what the creepy uncle is.
Because I'll never...
I'll never leave you alone.
Oh, the creepy uncle.
again guys don't worry i've learned my lesson you got some
more purple gunk here i think i have to spray this and then
like unearth something oh this oh here water this plant
water the pink flowers i'm the coolant what the am i doing
where are you oh do i have to grow this Oh, I have to make
this pretty again.
Right?
It has to be.
Oh, yeah.
I had to make it beautiful.
All right, I held him.
I held him.
I'm not over there.
Okay.
All right.
We gotta hurry.
I held him.
That's the plan.
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
Okay, I got it.
I got it.
Don't worry.
You did not get it.
I got it.
Do you know she be reviving?
I'm holding on him.
Oh, God.
I'm getting shot at.
I am one HP.
I'm holding.
He's literally one hit.
It's okay.
I need to get rid of the flyers first.
Okay, don't worry, I got you.
Anyways, maybe that's why I'm not normal.
And that's how you do it.
Wait, how do we hold...
Oh, okay, there you go.
Can I help out with this?
It looks like you are.
I'm the cool ant.
Dude, I feel like I told you so much...
Well, not you, but I feel like I told you chat so much about
my childhood and past, like, you takes two streams.
Like, me talking to Clay when I was younger.
Anyways.
Oh yeah, the clay story.
Yeah, the clay story.
Yeah, when I was locked up- You made like clay- Yeah, now we
sort of know why you're like this.
No, my family was so tough on me when I was younger for like
when they were grounding me.
There was one time they made me copy the entire To Kill a
Mockingbird book by him.
What?
In one week.
And I couldn't do it.
What did you do?
But like, why?
I got a C.
Oh, you got a C from- for your book report?
No.
They just decided to do that as a punishment Like, but why
did it kill?
It was this like first book they found?
Yeah.
So how did you...
So how was the book?
I didn't...
Well, I read the book.
I read it.
The thing is...
So like, how was the book, though?
I didn't finish the assignment.
Wait, did I even finish it?
You guys...
And because I didn't finish it, I had to get locked in my
room for a whole week.
Also, we were supposed to go to the other side and water
this area.
Oh, my God.
So how did you...
So no one...
So that's why you don't like reading.
No, I love reading.
Wait, then why don't you finish to kill a mockingbird?
I did.
I finished it, like, four times.
You just said you didn't.
I didn't finish writing it by hand, man.
Oh, then when I asked you, how was the book?
You were like, oh, I didn't finish it.
Oh, and I asked me how was, like, finished writing it?
I said, how was the book?
Do you like it?
That's pretty good.
I liked it.
Okay, but did you like it because of the punishment that you
got Stockholm syndrome for it?
Or did you actually like it?
Maybe.
It could have been Stockholm.
Yeah, I was going to say, it could have been Stockholm
syndrome because of...
Because you wrote so much of it, you just had to like it at
that point.
How the fuck do we fix this...
Fix this plan?
How do we fix this?
What?
She had to read it to be able to argue her way out the
gulag.
No.
I got the gulag.
Holy shit.
How the fuck do we?
I had to plant more.
But I planted so much.
Oh, you want the blue.
It was like this tiny patch!
That's so stupid.
It was like literally the tiny patch.
tanya's fucking clash of little tanya's thing that i didn't
fucking planted don't worry i'm helping the one spot
anyways uh that's all the childhood stories i have for you
today i think like the most exciting thing from my childhood
was um was when like i was alone in my i was my parents left
me home alone and then like i i made like this makeshift
fishing pole and like i sat in my and there was this drawer
thing so i would like pretend i'd be fishing and stuff um i
would i went to my parents room i was like pretending i'm
fishing and then my hook accidentally hooked into the drawer
like this giant drawer cabinet thing and then i put me being
a little dumbass was like oh my god i caught a big fish and
then i like pulled it so that the entire drawer like fell
down but like I was so lucky because like I freaked out and
I freaked out and I like dropped down and then the beds like
you know like the backboards the front board thing where are
you where why didn't you leave but like the bed like front
board thing blocked the drawer cabinet from squishing me So
I could have been dead.
I could have actually died.
And then what's fucked up was that...
My parents, like, recently, they, like, found...
Because they...
The furniture for our old furniture when I was little, my
childhood furniture and stuff was being stored somewhere.
And then my parents recently got the furniture out.
Like now that drawer that almost squished me is in my
bedroom
And then when my mom like when my parents like moved it into
my bedroom to like remember this drawer Doki do you remember
this drawer?
That's the drawer that almost killed you and I was like oh
Memories What the fuck I'm saying to God.
Oh, I see I'm Oh my god, it's boss battle time.
No, joy.
Maybe we're too late.
Ew, it's breathing at us.
Oh my god.
She cute.
It's okay, we're here to help.
It's Cody.
I made you.
Hello, beautiful flower.
Oh, she crazy.
I like that.
Oh I can fix her
Wait wait wait wait wait Wait I need to be immersive here.
I need Wait give me a second There has to be like some
immersion here.
Let me know before you unpause.
Okay.
Okay, I'm ready.
Are you ready?
I'm ready though.
No, I'm not ready.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
Okay, I'm ready.
Okay, okay.
I'm ready.
I'm ready for the immersion.
It's immersion time.
Oh my god, I'm stronger as a tomato too.
Look how strong I am
It's lower accurate who would have thought and you'll be the
husband was the right idea I knew I was meant to be a
husband There you Okay, I'm literally watching you.
I think you need to okay.
I'm trying to do it to no No!
My show is so short-lived.
It's okay.
That's all of them, may?
Give me some water over there.
What do I do?
She has a name?
Yeah, you named her.
I named her?
Yeah.
Your wife.
Oh, you're what?
You jealous?
Are you jealous?
I am.
aren't you, Gumi?
You wish you had this.
I actually am not.
I'm just surprised that's happening in front of my face.
You wish.
Now you regret what you can't have.
No, I think I'm chill, actually.
What are you here?
Where's this?
I see that.
Joy don't no don't do it I can fix you joy think of all the
good things we did together oh this is like baby's first
platformer it's like Cuphead are you It's baby's first
platform.
I'm still alive.
I don't know what you're talking.
Oh, wait, wait.
Okay, I made it I made it too Look at that No, I think I
think this flower is better than poison ivy because she's
more plant She doesn't need a compensate by being half human
She's full plant and that's why we love her What are you on
about, man?
What?
You don't think she's hot?
Look at her.
That's my new wife you're talking to.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, is it time?
It's, oh, I'm a potato.
I'm a potato.
Really?
You really think now is the time for jokes?
You know what you think?
We're gonna spit more purple stuff.
I'm washing it.
The freakiest ones are the ones with, like, multiple eyes.
Like, the potatoes with multiple eyes.
Have you seen that?
Yeah.
That shit is so freaky.
Where the fuck is the...
Where's the... Oh, there it is.
I'm on it.
Just don't hurt my new wife!
She's too beautiful to die.
And a little... She's too crazy to die.
I like them a little crazy.
Alright, get in her!
Don't worry!
Watch this.
I think I'm getting through to her.
Are you watching?
I need to be sure that you're watching.
I'm busy.
Okay.
Get over here.
You have to go down my arm.
My beautiful, sexy arm.
But I'm going to do what's best for you.
Oh my god, it's from my back.
Hey, up here.
I've got it open again.
Don't stick your fertilizer into crazy oh my god you can't
tell me what to do i'm gonna put all the fertilizer oh my
god so she'll grow up big and strong just like how the
gardener likes it
what's gonna happen i don't understand this
What?
What is this?
What is she gonna do?
Oh.
Oh, okay.
It's just dodging again, but this time we're in the air.
It's just dodging with extra steps.
Easy.
Let's go.
We're so smart.
Oh.
now there's less okay it's okay okay the the plate to the
right is gonna break not yet this place is definitely gonna
break though what i tied them perfectly don't die don't die
i'm good now whoa here send to wait that don't die don't die
I didn't drive it perfectly.
Look, it is easy.
I'm just trying to make you look good.
Well, you've been doing that quite a bit.
I mean, you clearly meet the win here.
Nice.
Don't worry.
Are you ready to watch again?
Oh my god.
I'm 11.
It's alive.
Look at me go.
Oh my god, it's making squeaky noises.
Oh my god!
Here we go.
I'm doing it.
Where's the other one?
Oh, the other one's right here.
A lime is just a lemon that just wants to be special.
Okay, get over here.
I'm trying to...
She's got major flip energy.
Okay, you have to kill that one guy.
oh my god i'm trying to wash the floor please watch the
watch the group this lemon is not doing so well there's one
more here one more here all right oh my god i'm cracking
right now all right we're good are you watching
now turn around i need you to keep watching She spawns!
She spawns!
Well, three times?
Damn, Cody!
That's what you know is true love.
Alright, I need you to hit my head.
And we're gonna get rid of it once and for all!
We're doing it.
Oh, they can't even touch you.
Yeah, that bastard better not touch you.
Don't look away!
I told you she's beautiful.
It really is.
Oh my god.
Are you okay?
Wife?
I am now.
Whoa.
Why can't you be nice like Joy?
Don't thank me.
I don't want you, man.
Go ahead.
Date a flower.
I'm sorry.
fuck am i sorry about how important it was for cody bro are
you the that's good oh my god look we got an approval
oh she's because i got caught but aren't
she caught me with my joy she didn't believe in me no one
can yeah idiot unless you give it up it's all up to you will
you give it up again don't worry joy i'll never give you up
you're clearly better than this i'll never give you up joy
happy let me look at it she's so pretty oh my god imagine
being this fucking kid and seeing these things happening bro
she clearly she already has trauma it's just gonna oh my god
it's a stupid clown thing you know octopus oh yeah i still
can't believe like like a millennial bought a fucking jack
in the box i mean to be fair she's already like going
through trauma so it's just like one more thing for her
therapist hey that's what my family said too
hey fuck it make me the right to kill a mockingbird again
letter piece number three and now how do you find your
purpose in life through passion again i already have joy now
it's time to find yeah who's your joy who's your joy who's
your joy everyone has a passion who's your side piece oh i'm
getting a phone call you want me to stay stay up late at the
office again oh we have overtime again oh god you want me to
wear something nice for over Don't worry, Jeremy.
What the fuck was that?
Yeah, we really need to clean up our attic.
Hey, you recognize this suitcase?
What is that?
Oh, I don't like where this is going.
Uh-oh.
Does that beep boombox?
It's a record player.
Oh.
Welcome to the concert hall.
May, it's time to sing.
Oh, no, no, no.
I can't sing.
I haven't done it for years.
Come on, May.
He won't give us the last letter piece unless you sing.
You just get up on that stage and you show him what you've
got.
All you have to do is sing.
I have to fucking...
I have to fucking save my garden and save my joy.
Oh, my God.
My joy was singing.
I'm not going to sing a single note.
Who are you singing with?
I'm gonna turn it to musical.
Oh, what?
What the fuck?
Is this the musical episode?
Every show has one.
And they're always terrible.
Oh, it's like that fucking singing game.
What was it?
The clapping?
Have you ever seen that singing game where you have to
actually sing in the microphone to actually get stuff done?
Okay, let me swap back my skin suit.
I feel a little naked.
Let me change real quick.
I'm a little naked here.
Give me a sec.
anymore i won't sing and make a fool of myself all right i'm
good one hand clapping what yeah one hand clapping that's
what it reminds me of yeah yeah yeah it's like this it's
like it like you actually sing in the mic and then like and
then it like fucking uh registers your voice and stuff what
do i do with this fucking oh it's like a little discus what
are you supposed to do here whoa is that game over there
yeah that's the game that's the waste track hey cody over
here all right complete three laps to win me at the lost
things which way does it go though oh it's on the left am i
what color am i oh i'm green how do you do that what What
are you doing to it?
I don't know!
I don't!
How are you controlling it?
I'm not controlling you, man.
Oh, we can't go too fast!
Oh!
Look, instructions unclear.
I didn't know you could...
It didn't say.
It didn't tell me that you had to slow down.
I just assume we go fast and we turn.
Okay, I'll be honest, I've just been tapping it.
okay i understand now don't worry i can catch up i can
clutch up right here rematch no no no rematch i understand
rematch rematch rematch
this time this time now that i know the game
whoa whoa wait how are you so faster to be
I know my limits
Ooh the backstage This is where I'm gonna meet Jeremy Yeah
he's my manager Oh whoa What the fuck Why is it so scary Oh
My abandoned dreams live here.
This is where your hopes and dreams die.
Oh, this symbol is like a shield.
I'm the symbol superhero.
Why didn't I get a shield?
You got the greatest weapon of all.
Yeah, your voice.
Oh.
See, I can still be romantic.
This is a powerful man.
Never forget that.
Name is there.
Oh, I have to cut this myself.
Oh, what the fuck?
You can kill stuff with your voice.
Oh, who broke the fucking...
Someone broke the lever here.
We're not alone.
Oh, that's cool, actually.
Okay.
How do we do this?
Oh!
Yeah, it is like one hand clapping.
Ow!
What?
Does it get too hot?
Oh!
You have to keep singing, because it gets hotter.
When it's, like, up, it cools down.
Yeah, see?
You have to keep singing!
Do I have to make you get all the way over there?
I think so.
Right?
Yeah, you have to keep singing for now.
Oh, I think it...
What?
Is there a pathway?
I feel like it...
keep singing until...
Because there's a there's a thingy on my thingy, too.
There's a thing?
Oh!
Wait, what?
Wait, I can jump and sing at the same time.
Oh, okay.
You know what?
I thought it was one of those that I had to stand still for.
Yeah, yeah, but you can actually move when you're singing.
I... How did I miss?
It's okay.
What?
Oh, hey, hey, you have to come back.
Hey, hey, I missed the last jump.
Hey, hey, hey, wife.
We're still not finalizing our divorce yet.
Wife.
Hey, wife.
You can't go there without me.
Try dying now.
Okay.
See if it gets you this.
Hey, wife.
Oh, my God.
Look, I know you don't want me to meet Jeremy, but I let you
meet my joy.
So I think it's...
fair uh i think it's fair that you know we meet each meet
each other's you know happiness
all right nice i'm here now don't worry i can't miss this
time i'm out um i'm out just keep singing i asked the bar
was empty all right okay all right you come back and like
chill okay never mind i guess not i guess not i guess i come
back and chill i i came back okay all right all right all
right look we can do this this cannot be the puzzle that we
struggle the most what do you mean we can do this cannot be
puzzle that we we are married so our our troubles are shared
i've already signed a prenup i forgot to sign the prenup
what all right here we go see look at that we did it
together it's not a skill it's a group skill issue yeah all
right i guess i go up oh maybe i might cut this?
No?
Oh, I have to cut the thing over here.
Wait, no, I have to get you over here.
Wait, how did you get here?
How did you get here?
I didn't look.
There's a microphone right here.
Oh!
Woo!
I did it.
You're welcome.
Oh, oh.
What the fuck?
Your grandpa was sick as hell.
Oh my god.
You think it still works?
All right, we need to grab the last coin.
All right.
There we go.
Ooh, look at that funky beat.
I wish my grandpa could see us now.
He'd love it.
Or hate it.
Okay, we have to go this way.
I love my grandpa.
The love of his life.
I'm pretty sure if we sell this, we can get a lot of money.
What the fuck?
I'm just saying, if somehow, you know, somehow I go broke, I
have to thank Grandpa for this.
Wait, what do we...
Oh, go over there?
Yeah.
Wee!
I need this thing here.
What's this for?
Oh!
Oh, I have to break this.
Wait, I'm breaking my grandpa's jukebox?
That's fucked up.
Keep going.
Keep shouting.
Keep destroying my hopes and dreams because it doesn't
matter anymore.
These are my hopes and dreams.
This is my grandpa's jukebox.
What do you mean?
Oh, now you left me.
to add it because you just stopped caring.
Okay, now I have to push.
Jesus, what the fuck is that?
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I have to bring this up.
I was like, why is this working?
Alright.
Put down.
Okay, here we go.
we're upping up the base oh shit you going all right I'm all
the way up
what the heck where are we why do you have all this
equipment I thought this was just a hobby good work both of
you you've earned the speakers we've earned speaker what's
the speaker for keep on going you're still missing the mics
and lines
what the hell i'll use your symbol for it oh i blocked the
thing with my symbol watch this bam my lady Oh, no thank you
Shivery's dead Wait Wait, what do you mean?
Baa
Wait, why can't I fucking get past this?
Oh, I have to go like that Still no thank you Fucking
Shivery's dead Oh, look, look, look over there What?
You have to do something over here.
I do?
No, I don't.
No, look at this pad because it matches colors with these.
Wait, what?
Wow!
I'm starting to like this place.
Oh, you have to go B.
Oh, yellow, yellow.
I think?
And then you take me straight up.
Wait, what?
D then?
Oh, it's D.
Oh, the B base!
Wait, how do we go up?
Oh, no!
B, B, B.
Yellow?
Yellow, yellow, yellow.
Green.
A, not orange, orange, orange.
Okay, keep going.
Orange.
Which way is this?
Ah, wrong way!
You guys...
I gotta send it back.
Okay, I figured it out.
I'm not on it.
I'm not on it!
Oh, I thought I had to send it back.
Okay.
Alright.
Uh, a, uh, orange, orange, orange.
Orange.
Okay.
Uh, purple.
Uh, orange.
Oh my god, I can't see.
Uh, orange, uh, purple, purple, purple.
Purple.
Uh, green.
Oh my god, we're so smart.
Green.
Uh, purple.
Yeah!
We did it!
Look at this teamwork!
Oh god.
We got it.
You mean, oh god.
I was the one that had to dodge the fucking fuse.
And bam!
Bam!
There you go.
Now you're...
Don't wonder my hopes and dreams are over.
That's fucking right.
When you get married, you can never have any more hopes and
dreams.
Our child is our hopes and dreams now.
That's why we live like usually through the child.
Oh my god!
Time to tell another story.
Yeah, time to give the child unrealistic expectations.
expectations now because my hopes and dreams are dead
i'm okay by the way wait oh yeah this thing okay
all right yay yay i don't even have to go here this thing
here
wait where are you going Oh, here?
Oh, there's something here.
I can picture it now.
A young man.
Rebellious.
Whoa!
Oh, shush.
Up we go.
Uh-oh.
This is not a hobby at that point.
You've- how much money have you invested in this?
Is this where- What'd you like to know?
There's way too many things here for a hobby.
Oh, how do we do this?
Trust me.
I know how to turn out.
Yeah, trust me.
Oh, it's like I'm fucking marshmallow.
Drop this.
I don't know how marshmallow does it.
I'm coming down.
Are you ready for the drop?
Have you seen that TikTok video of like 19, like the 1920s,
uh, dance club remix?
Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Whoa, whoa.
Don't worry, DJ Doki's here.
Whoa!
This is Tripp.
Oh my god.
How do I...
Okay.
Wait, what?
The top was too.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay.
And then you jump right here.
Right there.
Yeah, yeah, I got it.
Jump, jump.
And then...
Oh, I went the wrong way, but it's okay.
I went the right way now.
The right way.
Okay.
There you go.
What the hell is happening?
That shit is trippy.
I like that mechanic.
You've seen osmosis jumps?
All right.
I need you to...
No, I'm not high enough.
I'm good, I'm good.
All right, turn on.
Oh, we're recording!
Get ready to sing!
What's that?
Can you sing?
I don't know.
Nope, there.
Goodbye, your hopes and dreams.
Me lied.
No more singing for you.
What so?
Oh wait, what's this?
Oh, he angie.
Oh, you sing to it!
Oh, you're like a snake charmer!
Oh.
Then...
Go up.
Oh, they're like little snakes!
There you go.
Good job, Cody!
We're gonna kill your love.
We're gonna kill all your dreams here.
Oh, it moves!
Wait, you need to sing to it.
Okay, give me a second.
You need to sing to it.
He's on me!
I'm so far!
I'm too far!
I'm dead.
Where am I going?
Am I dead forever?
No.
Okay.
Alright, I'm going to push you over.
You need to keep singing to it.
Keep singing to it.
I'm running out!
and he is singing to it he's looking at me all right he's
dead all right i got bored i know you did
oh there's one above us sing what the fuck why can't i wait
keep saying singing oh yeah I got it when these spikes not
hurt us oh they do hurt us they're made of foam why would
these spikes hurt it's literally foam okay nice you have to
keep singing though the snakes want to hurt us what how
hello I'm Well, I hope you're doing okay because I might be
stuck here I don't think there's a way for me to get back
over it's here.
Oh No, no, you just have to die.
You have to die and come back because I'm literally
softlocked I'm stuck here.
Oh no Wait, you can come back.
Okay
What?
This is a group effort, all I'm saying.
Okay, let me recharge for my C.
I'm ready.
Okay.
Look at that, see?
Look, it's not my fault.
This is a group effort.
I'm recharging.
Alright.
We'll go up.
I'm here.
Everything's fine.
Are you ready?
Uh-huh.
What?
What the fuck?
Oh!
Don't worry, I'm coming back.
I thought the thing was behind us.
Oh!
I thought you were there, but it's okay.
I'm coming back.
I've just fed the snake again.
Oh, guys.
We did it as a team.
Oh.
What was that?
Oh, big snake.
This is such a cool design, though.
Yeah, that is a cool design.
cool like that's so creative for making it a snake oh no oh
no it's crash bandicoot again it's crash bandicoot okay the
amount of fucking uh money you we have spent on these
microphones though i think we need to talk about where you
got this money from i worked for it yeah but like do not
care about our daughter's college tuition
Do you not care?
What about you?
Why aren't you picking up another job?
What do you mean?
Another job.
If you care so much, why don't you pick up a job?
Instead of paying attention to joy all day.
I literally took care of our...
Look at you.
I died.
She has school!
Who's going to take care of the house?
You come home at 9 p.m.
every day.
Who's going to take care of the house?
What the fuck?
I didn't even see that side.
I'm having my breathing thing Oh, he's getting closer All
I'm saying Is that you come home So fucking late Like, what
am I supposed to do?
I can't get a job If you're gonna not be at home Oh, not
gonna say anything Where are your parents?
Where are your parents?
Not gonna say anything Don't do I get it What the fuck?
I didn't know that What do you Why else would I have Why
else would I have the jukebox?
That's your grandfather's, man.
Oh, sorry.
I see my grandfather as my dad.
Because my dad left.
Two incomes are better than one.
Make doki work two jobs.
Farming is a job.
A humongous snake that almost killed us.
Did you say gardening?
And you earned...
Oh shit.
But they're all like cut up.
That's not...
what?
Wait.
See and kill my grandparents.
I didn't kill your grandparents, yeah?
What's this?
Show me your skills then.
Well you try too.
It's fun to make music together.
Alright.
Let's make a hit yo.
Let's make it hit, yo.
Oh!
That's it, right?
That is?
Oh, we have to do more?
Oh, we have to add more!
Oh, there we go, we got it, we're good.
Oh, look at that sick ass fucking beat.
Yeah, we made that.
We made that.
we're the next daft bug yeah what is what is our name daft
bunk okay well I think that's no cuz it's it's bunk not punk
it's like bunk beds we share bunk beds so we're daft bunk
like our our student our performance appearance like it's
like a bunk bed yeah you're on the top of no I'm on the top
of the bunk bed you're on the bottom of the bunk bed and we
DJ from there like the the beds are like our DJ platforms
like the DJ equipment and then we're like the daft bunks
because we it's so smart it'll be so cool people are gonna
love it and then we can sell like bunk beds as our like as
our product as our brand that
sounds lame you don't know art you don't know creativity
must be for you no thanks come on man you deserve to be in
the spotlight tap okay i guess it's my time to shine it's my
turn to be a star baby hey hey hey lights on me ow ow i can
get hurt if i'm not the center of the attention
pay attention to me or i'll get hurt all right yeah right
side okay center we're making progress out is it decent or
something because i feel what the fuck how do i get across
from that wait there's something here there's something oh
yeah there is okay ready yeah i'm ready go i can't see keep
going go go go go go go go go go go go go Whoa, what?
Oh, we have to move the other one.
Yeah, you have to...
Okay.
Why don't we get to the other side?
Do you have to look at it?
Oh, wait.
Do you have to go look at it?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That light is the platform.
Come on.
Be faster than me.
Oh.
Is it...
Do you think I'm something?
What's going on?
Because I'm on you.
I have no idea.
Where's your other light?
Oh.
Okay, stay right there.
Yeah.
All right.
You have to go get the left side?
The left side.
I know.
This light can only go left.
The red one can only go right.
Oh, okay.
And then...
Nice.
I'm panning over.
All right.
I'm going to go super fast.
Watch this.
Oh, now you go super fast.
Now you go.
All right.
Chase after me.
Turn on.
No.
Dude, I think there's actual decent because I was on you the
entire time and you still kept getting hurt.
Yeah, yeah, because you were not on me on my screen.
On my screen, I was directly on you.
Yeah, but I'm host.
I guess that's what happened with the grass too.
Oh, that's true.
Yeah, that should make sense.
What the hell?
Oh, my God.
Oh, you're gonna sing!
You know how my piece of music is like metal?
Yeah.
Um, dude, I fucking love being at the barricades, but I also
hate it at the same time.
Won't you get like pushed against it?
Oh yeah, you mush.
Yeah.
I only go to concerts if I can get VIP and I can like enter
in early to get towards the barricades, or else I'm not
really going.
Go and find an orchestra.
Can you not encourage him please?
Okay, okay.
If you sing.
Oh my god.
ready to sing in front of everybody this is it your hopes
and dreams i'm mad at wait is this chest this is actual
chess oh my god oh my god this is actual chess wait wait
this is quick game hey can we do we're not playing fucking
we're not infinite game we're doing quick there's no way not
other okay i've played chess in a long time though so i
don't know what i'm doing How do I make it quick?
Oh!
What if I just copy your every move?
What is wrong with you?
What if I just copy?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm not thinking any steps ahead.
I'm not either.
I'm just moving.
Me too.
I just moved.
I just wanted to get the horse out.
Me too!
Oh, the horsey!
The horsey!
Ney!
You want my horsey, then your horsey be friends?
Yeah.
No.
That's not so friendly, of course.
What if I don't want your horsey to be friends with my
horsey?
Well, can I get in this one?
Here she goes!
I want to move this horse.
This way.
I want to move my horse seat this way.
Oh my god they can kiss you.
They're so close?
What the fuck?
You don't even move your horse.
I'm like, what if they don't move like that?
You lied to me.
You lied to me?
I'm gonna let the king attack you.
The hell?
The king is coming head over.
But what if the king just walks up to you and just...
Wouldn't it be funny if I just lose my queen right here?
That would be so fucking hilarious.
If I just lose my queen right there.
That would be so funny.
I'd be like, hee hee ha ha.
I want my horse to go here.
Yeah, and I want my...
I want my king to stay right here and just look at you.
Okay.
Just look at you like that.
You know, just look at you.
Okay.
This one, give you a little look.
A little look.
You see?
I know I'm just gonna stare at you.
Okay.
He's just looking at you like that And I was like, hello
Is that cute?
Is that funny?
I heard you the first time
Wouldn't that be so funny?
Why aren't you in the chess club or something?
Yeah, but I don't care anymore I don't think when I play
chess anymore Because I don't play chess anymore I've never
played...
I learned how to play chess from the computer.
I don't play chess anymore, so I don't really care.
You know what?
I'm just gonna eat your horse.
You can eat my pawn, but, like, I got your horse.
I left my horse there, because you said our horses were
friend.
Well, is this a horse?
Is this a horse?
What the hell?
I mean, you're just gonna eat a pawn, so who cares?
I'm coming for your king soon!
Whoa!
That's fucked up!
What would you do that?
It's just a little funny horse.
I won't tell you.
Where is my king?
Literally looking at it.
Where's my king?
I'm literally looking at it.
Where is my king?
You were like, I'm gonna put my king here.
I'm gonna put my king here so it looks at you.
Because I want my king to look at you.
Where is it?
That's all you come saying.
I want my king to look at you.
Yeah, because I want to look at you.
I want to be like, see look, I exchanged my horse for your
horse because I was being nice.
I was like, yeah, I gave you my horse because I wanted to be
nice.
You mean it too?
Yeah.
What are you doing?
Don't ya.
I mean, what the fuck?
Why did you move your castle there?
That's fucked up.
Why did you do that?
Why should you move your castle over there?
That's mean.
Because I want to.
Why?
Why would you want that?
Because I want to...
Why?
Why would you want that, though?
Because I want to.
Why?
Um...
I forgot how to tie me.
I forgot.
Yeah, no, I was like, why the fuck is she just talking about
her?
Can't go into sand and like, why are you saying?
I forgot I had a tie me.
I was just fucking around.
This is supposed to be a quick game that I'm messing about.
Oh, there's your queen over there.
There she is.
It's over here.
She's right here.
She's over here.
Oh, you're going to move your bishop.
Yeah, I'm moving my bishop over here.
Okay.
I'm going to move this one.
Not that one.
Okay.
I'm going to move this one.
No, no, I'm going to move it right here.
Okay.
Okay, you move over there.
You move over there.
Okay.
I'm gonna move I'm gonna move Her over Where do I go Where
do I go Um you only have a minute 20 seconds Yeah I know
Stop me on you son of a bitch You think you're so smart You
think you're so smart
No Where are you gonna move Are you gonna move?
I want my horse.
No.
Not here.
That's fucked up.
Why did you move over there?
I wanted to be there.
But why?
Why did you want it to be there?
What purpose does it give you?
I just want it there.
I'm impressed.
By myself.
Why would you do that?
Check.
No, not check.
I'm JK.
That's not.
I thought this king was over here.
Whoops.
I wasn't looking.
JK, he, he, that was not Czech.
JK, I think I was just joking.
He, he, he, he, funny.
Wasn't that funny that I thought that was Czech?
Shut up, dude.
Yeah, that was kind of funny.
Is that funny?
That was pretty hee hee, right?
Yeah, that was kind of funny.
Isn't that hilarious?
Um, where do I want to go?
Um...
You don't know, you don't know where to go.
Where do you?
I don't know.
Why don't you think for like one more minute?
Just think for one more minute, you know?
Why did you go home?
Just think for one more minute.
Yes.
I wanted to go home.
Why did you go home?
Just keep thinking.
I wanted to.
I'll go here then.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Hello.
I want to send my horse home too.
Why are you sending your horse home?
Your horse just wants to have fun.
um you ate my other horse
um you actually have um 10 seconds left oh no what do i nine
um eight um seven um six um i've said seconds i can still do
stuff okay i'm playing my horse here okay i'm just gonna i'm
just gonna eat your pawn anyway because i have four seconds
That's fine.
Bye God.
What?
Just because you have more time?
We thought it was like more pieces.
But I ate more pieces didn't I?
Yeah, I have more pieces.
I thought...
Wait, it's... Oh, it's like whoever runs out of time.
Oh, you need to lose.
Oh my God, it's Heaven's gate.
Oh shit.
Your thing is off.
Not that good.
What the fuck?
Oh, it's time we checked me.
More instruments.
Yeah, you just got beat by a person who learned how to play
from a computer.
From running out of time.
That is...
Wait, we're out of heaven?
Bro, that was fast.
We're not in heaven.
anymore apparently there's um what's this wine oh yeah but
don't don't drink the wine don't drink the wine wow that's a
lot of wine you're a wine mom oh there's peaches don't like
wine that much wait wait wait where is it
oh look at that i can play twinkle twinkle little star I'm
not even playing Mary Had a Little Lamb.
Oh, it's actually the same tune.
Mary Had a...
Isn't it?
Twinkle.
No, there's like...
Row, row, row your boat.
Gently down the stream.
Twinkle.
There's like...
There's like tunes that are like basically the same tune.
And then it's like...
What are you doing?
I'm waiting for you.
How do I get there?
Go down.
Go down?
Oh!
Oh, you're downstairs!
I thought you were above me.
No.
There's something here.
But I'm over here.
And now I'm over here.
Now I'm back.
Alright, I'm ready.
Yippee!
We're so smart together.
What did that do?
I don't know.
Oh, oh, I see.
I sent you the vines.
Oh, buh buh, black sheep.
Have you any wool?
Yes, sir.
Three bags full.
What the fuck?
Whoa, what's this?
You have an accordion?
Oh, it kills you.
Oh, what's that machine?
It looks like some kind of accordion.
How do we fucking...
Do you think he's against it?
Oh, I can shield!
Guys, remember when I have a shield?
I got it.
Malady?
You have to stand behind my shield, I'm worth something now.
Oh my god!
That's sick!
I'm black!
Right side.
To the right, to the right.
Here we go, we're good.
We just run past it.
Trivary is not dead, exactly.
But some- I don't even need her to say thank you.
I mean, it would be nice, you know?
Oh, you say so?
Oh, yeah, to the left side.
Left!
Right!
Okay, I got it.
It should stay open now.
Yeah.
Here I go.
Wee!
Oh, I have to wait for you.
No, I don't.
I can just be here.
Oh, I need to go on the other side.
Me!
You need to, like, jump off my head.
It's a fun little song.
I don't need the little notes come off the paper.
Oh, yeah, that's so cute.
I like that.
Yay!
Where the fuck are we?
Are we in a cello or something?
How much music do you play?
How do we have all these instruments?
We'll be back in music heaven?
Dude, why the fuck are we in heaven?
Because we're good people.
Well, obviously, I think I'm a good person.
I gave you my pass.
I gave you my plus one.
Okay, sure.
Lying is a sin, you know.
Yeah, that's why I gave you my pass.
And why you're not in heaven.
They must have gone home for the day.
Let's just cancel the whole thing.
No, no, no, me.
You have to bring the orchestra to your concert.
What?
What kind of concert is this?
I thought this was a pop concert.
They've been kidnapped?
Kidnapped by the devil.
They're the devil?
Um, in heaven?
Oh, yeah.
Makes total sense.
Right, huh?
Huh?
Exactly.
But now you have to go and save the orchestra.
Go.
How?
Aren't we technically walking on?
Oh, okay.
I thought we were already on clouds.
Jump.
Alright.
Time to kill the devils.
Wait, but where do we go?
Go here?
Oh my god, there's flying pigs.
Oh my god, when pigs fly!
But where are the music notes for?
Oh, we have to get all the music notes.
I get the cutscene and you don't want.
I got the cutscene before you.
Wait, then why do I have to watch it again?
Alright, just a few more bubbles to pop.
Once you pop, you can't stop.
We get all the ones here?
No, we're missing one.
Oh, it's up here.
I got one of the doors up.
Oh my god, I see the devils!
Come on!
Wait, can I kill the pigs?
Oh, my god, stop!
Wait, there's tennis!
There's tennis!
Oh, volleyball!
I love volleyball.
Okay, jump is nice.
Why?
I scared you?
Oh, my god, look.
It's a devil bat!
Yeah, it's a devil and a pig.
The angels are pigs?
That's funny, the angels are pigs.
Wait, this is not real volleyball.
This is not regular volleyball.
How dare they tarnish volleyball?
I can't believe.
Not my volleyball.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Dude.
I know, it gets confusing when there's two.
Nice.
Alright.
Woo!
Yeah!
I wish we made it more clear that you were under it.
It's like, it's so weird, like, because it's, like, hard to
see where the ball's gonna land too.
I think that's, like, the more frustrating part.
Yeah.
It's...
What?!
I was clear!
I hate this game!
I hate this game.
It ruined volleyball for me.
Not my body.
I told you!
This sucks!
What?
You got two!
You get the hit, both!
Nice kill!
Oh god.
Bro, it's getting harder.
It's going harder.
It's getting...
Okay.
Oh,
out of here.
Oh, God.
Bro!
The devil is reaching the game!
This is it.
Dude, fuck these pigs.
Down with all the angel pigs.
Where are they?
I'm coming over!
No, I can't kill him!
No,
I can't get rid of them.
I'll pet you.
I guess I'll pet you.
But they're not pigs.
They're like little hamsters.
Yeah, what the heck?
Yeah.
Oh my god, his face is so cute.
Look at his little paws.
Yeah, he has little paw pads too.
He's not gonna stop me from eliminating him.
Stop!
They ruined volleyball!
They didn't do shit!
We're like the devils!
I'm waiting for you on the other side.
Well, I'm clearing out the music net so we can just get out
of the way.
We're going to head there eventually anyway.
I'm right here with the devil here.
Oh, you got to get that KD ratio up.
You're right.
You sweet.
You're a fucking dick.
Oh, whoa.
Why do they have faces?
Where's the orchestra?
Bro, oh.
find them god that one's throwing ass
oh sorry cloud my bad no wait look oh he's crying hidden in
the fog or those are guys those voice actors are so reckon
like i feel like i know them the voice actors oh yeah
they're so crazy devils because we're about to bring it so I
just have to beat up the clouds that's easy okay sorry
clouds you need your tears to clear the fog don't worry I'm
making them all cry they like it their tears of joy oh I
pushed the clouds over oh you pushed them over so I've been
beating up for no reason
I've been...
Stop beating this one's ass, dude.
I just look over and this is cause extra sad.
What if they like it?
You don't know that.
Is that why they're crying and look so sad?
They like it.
They're tears of... Okay, it's like those like...
They're tears of joy.
I'm pretty sure I just heard this one say, oh no, no, no.
I think you're supposed to move them around so like we- it
clears the fog, right?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure you're supposed to- All the fog?
Yeah, I'm pretty sure you're supposed to clear the fog.
Yeah, see?
Do you hear it?
It's like tears of happiness.
I hear those tears of happiness right there.
Oh, there it is!
We have them here!
There we are!
We gotta beat them up!
Beat them up!
There we go.
I got one?
Where's the last guy?
I got two.
Where's the last one?
Was there three?
I thought there was three.
No, there was only two, because they had two keys.
Oh!
But where's the key then?
I didn't want to get the cloud thing up.
I didn't want to make sure the fog is still clear.
Because I don't see any keys.
Where the fuck?
Don't worry, I got you.
Oh my god, he looks so miserable.
He looks so happy.
Oh, there it is!
I knew there was one more.
Yeah, there's the other one.
I got it.
Wait, where's the other one?
other key then.
Wait, do you have...
Is there someone in the floor somewhere?
Yeah, you must have dropped it on the floor.
Because where is it?
Where's the last key?
I think it has to be, like, in the fog somewhere.
Oh, wait!
There's a guy!
Oh, there he is!
I didn't even see him.
Do I have it?
Don't!
Dragoon, you like that Dragoon?
What the heck?
Get over here!
I'm here.
Let me save one of them.
half of the orchestra you think they're they're dead people
we are in heaven oh my god that could be mozart right there
let's get to the other side yeah we cool like that we could
have had betoven i actually call him mozzy we're just you're
that close yeah yeah and betoven called baby
He's like he's in heaven so like technically he's still
alive Yeah, excuse me devils.
Yeah, we're we're gonna need to borrow that orchestra that
you got locked up in there We will never let them out.
I'm glad you also noticed.
Yeah, yeah.
I was like, yeah.
Whoa!
We can just beat up all of them.
Okay, but what if we just hit everything?
Yeah, if I kill everybody, then we win.
There you go.
I got the key one.
I got the key.
I've just been killing all of them.
Yeah, me too.
too, honestly.
Okay, I'll grab this one, though.
Whoa, wait, they can steal from you?
Bro, that's fucked up.
Don't worry, I got another one.
That's fucked up as we're killing all of them.
Yeah, we're killing all your friends and family, and you're
just gonna focus on the key.
We're missing one more.
Oh, wait, you already killed him.
I like how we killed all of them instead of the actual
person with the key.
Well, they were gonna steal it anyways.
We did it!
Oh.
Why don't you say anything?
We're supposed to be a team.
It looked like you were having fun.
Yay!
Now we say chopping!
Oh my god.
Reminds me of a sound of music.
Is that it?
Now we need to get the maestro.
You're the maestro.
That's the whole thing.
I wonder if I can die.
Wait.
I'm going to test Ethereal.
You can die.
Okay.
Look, it's all about experimentation.
Leave it alone!
Wait, what?
What did I do?
Dude, I'm so glad I saw one more on your screen, too.
Pretty impressive, right?
I just didn't want to tell you.
Don't worry, it'll be fine.
No, no, no, no.
It will not be fine.
He gets to go to double heaven.
It will be fantastical.
Whoa.
Oh.
Rematch time.
I see.
the chessboard.
What the fuck?
Good job.
We're almost ready.
The only thing missing is the audience.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Not an audience.
Do you want the last letter piece or not?
Hey, that's blackmail.
No.
That's manipulation.
Now go and get it.
Blackmail and our relationship is a healthy relationship.
I didn't get to reply earlier, but you We're right.
Like, there are some marriages that are, like, that need to
be ended.
Like, you can't fix all marriages.
This is one of them.
Edge.
Oh, my God.
VIP.
We're VIP.
That's us.
Let us in.
Hey, buddy.
Over here.
What's up?
Can you let us in?
Sorry, kids.
No minors.
Kids?
No, no, no, no.
We're just, uh, we're small in size.
I can't believe it just because we're small Excuse me.
We are adults You have some ID oh No, we left it at home.
That's what they all say Yo yo Glowstick there with me dr.
Akeem a bro there with you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, dude's right stick
together Sorry about that Welcome to the club enjoy the
evening The IP is coming through Not so cocky anymore, are
you?
Huh?
Yeah.
Fucking yell at the body.
Yell at the fucking bouncer.
That's a good idea.
Oh my god, Rainbow Road!
Rainbow Road?
Nintendo's coming.
What?
Here we go.
I call left.
It's already going right, man.
call left.
Oh my god, it is!
It's literally Mario Kart!
They're like, if you fall off, but you get the really?
Yeah, look, look!
Oh my god.
Bro, I'm telling you, Ted.
Power world, and now this?
To statistics, do they never learn?
What are left to to the left.
Everything he own and a box to the left.
And the bedroom please don't leave.
I'm still in the front.
What the fuck?
I died to experience it, man.
No one told you to die.
Come on.
You could have just looked at my screen, so I'm saying.
I don't screen peek.
Yeah, yeah, you don't screen peek.
You've been screen peeking since we started.
Oh my god, that's scary.
Yeah, or else you're gonna be like, Oh, Goomy, where's my
context clues?
Oh, it's like those little, like, the spring...
What were they called?
Those little spiral things in the 90s?
Oh, the Slinkies?
Slinkies, yeah!
Do you know there's people who do, like, play with Slinkies
as a job?
I've seen people do that.
Like, magic tricks and stuff.
have you seen like those like but it's like a job or
something because people hire them for party entertainment
slinkies yeah i saw like a fucking youtube short of it they
like people like like they get hired or some shit to like do
like slinky tricks yeah slinky artists what the fuck why am
i stuck on this side oh god this is really annoying
Okay.
This is so annoying, actually.
Yeah, anything can be a job if there's a demand.
That's true.
Wait for me.
You're a lovely husband.
I need to press that.
You don't know about me.
Are you fucking...
Really?
He opened that and you won't allow me.
Oh, I need you there.
Open, open, open, open sesame, open sesame, open sesame!
I watched it, please.
I'm here anyway.
What is this?
Where in the area that they like...
Wait, make the...
Oh.
Like the disco buff.
Yeah, we have to do this together.
Boom.
Oh.
Oh my god.
No, my symbol!
No!
You lost your symbol!
Move it, Cody!
Move it!
Down, stance, Cody!
Do I have to move anywhere?
Oh, wait.
Wait, I don't.
No, I do!
I thought you'd just stand there.
I thought you learned from the first time, but you just
didn't.
I couldn't tell.
My perception.
My death perception was off.
Because he's moving still.
So I assume he's moving for me.
Bump, bump, bump, bump, bump.
Woo.
Holy shit.
How long is this road?
I thought we just had to do...
Oh.
I just...
Oh, shit.
I thought we just had to do an orchestra.
Why is she...
Your hobby and passion, so long and complicated.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's okay.
You're still alive.
I'll just wait.
You can do this.
I believe in you.
When you don't press anything, it auto-presses for you.
So you are forced to.
I've heard that one time you kept dying on purpose.
Not even on purpose.
He's just...
I kept dying!
Whoa.
Wait, this is that punk!
Oh, look at our lime trails!
There's colors behind us.
What's that one movie?
I'm glad I didn't have to do it alone.
What, Tron?
Yeah, Tron!
I love Tron.
They're making a sequel.
I never watched it.
Fun.
Why not?
A jellyfish!
Wait, whoa, whoa, whoa, this is trippy.
Wait, where's the jellyfish?
I don't see it.
No!
I was looking at the fucking glow.
Oh my god.
That's me when I go to my concert.
Oh.
Hey, we didn't see anything.
What do we do?
Stop the music.
Okay, baby.
come on no they're leaving we're killing the vibes can't be
me i like i like that maybe they will if you leave the dance
floor yeah dude seriously i think you're scaring them no way
baby i'm killing it can't you see my hip jarring oh crunch
look at this right left right left but make the audience
dance you need to play the music get the audience on the
floor let's dj baby i don't know if this guy tells me to say
all that i don't think i want to be at the club anymore yeah
all right how do we do this figure out this dj thing oh do
it make them dance that's it you just spin the thing oh my
god that's all they need a fog machine and so they can't see
what's going on in front of them no consequences when you
can't see is that it if there's no consequences if you don't
know what's happening oh this one you have to dance you have
to go to the circle and dance too oh you have to do this I'm
turning the thing I'm turning it there Oh my god, we're
doing it!
Now we dance!
Look at us go!
Oh my god, it's...
It's time to actually dance.
Dance as Revolution.
I used to have those dance pads as I did.
I had a Mario one.
There's a Mario one?
Oh, we'll do all of this now.
Oh my god.
The bar, the bar, the top bar!
I'm trying!
Oh no, they can see the consequences!
their actions!
They need more fun!
They don't want to know what's going on!
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum!
Ladies and gentlemen, DJ Cody and MC May!
Yeah, DJ Cody's here.
Yeah, it's totally not cringe.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Oh my god, look at the crowd, they're dancing for us!
What the fuck?
What the fuck is he doing?
That's fucked up!
You spinny ra-ra-ra-ra-ra.
Oh, he plays
music and stuff.
Oh, I missed the fucking...
Ow!
How do you hit all of them?
Okay.
I'm hitting the music.
I'm riding the music.
Oh my god, how are you so fucking fast?
I don't know.
How are you doing that?
Are you cheating?
What do you mean am I cheating?
There's no way it can't be because I keep hitting every
obstacle.
There's no...
There's no way.
Oh my god, I'm being the jump.
Can't wait to see what that looks like.
Whoa.
Absolutely incredible.
I can't believe it made you skip ahead to the cutscene that
I'm at.
No, I just made it.
Whoa!
I was right beside you this entire time.
Aha!
We're...
Oh, that's so bright.
Holy shit!
That's so bright.
Look at them!
Yeah!
Look at that audience!
They're excited!
Yeah!
They're just heading to the after party!
Are we still missing something?
No, we got everything we need.
Showtime, baby.
Woo!
You hear that, May?
You hear the anticipation?
I haven't performed in front of an audience for ages.
May, it'll be fine.
Just think of them all in their underwear.
Yes, that would make you relax.
Got it.
Let's go prep the stage.
Okay, Buck.
Hey, May.
yeah break both legs and your arms what the fuck what is for
good luck i don't think the more bones you break the more
luck you get that's social business why do you tell people
to break the legs i i don't i don't yeah you were born to be
your arms and legs and your back to be you he said
What the fuck?
I don't get to play the game now?
What about me?
What are you doing?
Flight of the Barnes.
Oh, it would be so funny if that was to kill the Mockingjay.
Mockingjay!
Mockingbird!
Can you only walk?
Yeah, I can only walk.
It doesn't even let me crouch or anything.
Lily Fields.
Sing from the heart.
Sing from the heart, Gumi.
That's so nice.
I don't have to play the video game.
I get to do a watch along.
It's React content time.
Doki reacts to Gumi's gameplay.
Oh my god.
What is Gumi gonna do now?
What the fuck is that?
Is that me?
Oh shit!
Gumi react time.
What do I have to say?
This isn't my dream and hope.
Oops.
This is...
Am I just walking too?
Whoa.
Look at all these people here for you.
There has to be at least 5,000 people there.
That does not look like 5,000.
That looks like maybe 130.
That looks at least like 10,000 people in the audience.
No pressure.
Oh shit!
Joki reacts.
Alright, so Gumi is gonna walk straight in the line.
I wonder what's gonna happen, Chad.
I'm actually turning.
She's gonna start turning?
Oh, I think that, Chad, I think she's heading to the stage
that we just saw earlier.
Vehicle maintenance.
Oh, those are my books!
That's my shit!
Classic children's stories.
Oh, you're gonna start playing!
Are you even gonna sing?
Or is it maestro time?
Oh my god, it's the concert getting ready.
Oh my god!
They're all here for...
They don't have eyes, so they can't see if it's a bad
performance.
Dude, they were kidnapped.
They were literally kidnapped to be here.
You can do this.
I believe in you.
They have to clap.
If they don't clap, they stay here forever.
They can't go home to their families.
Oh yeah, the daughter.
I almost forgot about her.
She's like...
What's going on?
It's been like eight hours now.
Dinner was supposed to be ready an hour ago.
Mom, Dad, are you guys just...
I'm not an attic.
Mom, Dad, the music just started playing the attic above us.
Are there people that like, you know...
Do we have ghosts?
I thought...
I thought it was just us three.
Who's that?
Mom, wake up!
Mom, look!
Look what I found, Mom!
The sun is setting now!
Shut up, I'm sleeping.
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
This is so sad for the child.
There's so many things.
She has so many issues right now.
Like both their parents are unresponsive.
And like, I'm giving you my heart, mom.
I love you.
And then mom's just like, don't know, Wald.
Sing anaconda.
My anaconda, don't.
What done?
Okay, to be fair, like this audience is not there for
classic music.
Like, this is a rave audience.
We have the wrong fucking fans here.
Bro, they're so fucking bored.
Where are the words?
Where are the beats?
Where are flying?
Are we gonna kiss?
Oh my god.
With the power of music?
Are our kids running away from home right now?
Marriage saved.
That was beautiful, Mae.
Thank you.
I assume?
What?
Hold?
We're actually gonna...
No.
Fly away.
No!
Don't!
Everything!
Let go!
Oh, I can back away from you.
I can...
We stare deeply into each other's eyes.
Clink, clink, clink, clink.
Oh, but what if I don't?
Oh, that's right.
Getting the ick.
I'm getting the ick right now.
Unless I haven't finished the scene.
I'm getting the ick.
So, okay.
slow and steady and I go straight in but what if I stop?
Oh, it won't let me.
Please, I'm getting the egg!
And then I go...
Oh!
I'm actually like...
And then I stop.
Just close your fucking eyes Come on, just the two of us.
Just, I'm going to stare deep into your eyes.
My controller's vibing like crazy people.
Here, guys, here, this is the sound of the controller.
Wow, oh my god, it's right there.
See, first year, he loves.
He's like, get closer.
Get closer.
Almost there.
There you go.
Wait, is that even a kiss yet?
Cause I didn't close my eyes.
I like saw two different X's in the time frame.
Wait.
It's the slow burn.
Don't you like slow burn?
Oh, God.
That was like 130 chapters in.
This is it.
Oh no.
No, this is Stockholm syndrome taking effect right now.
Singing a song, this is just miraculously fucking fixing
marriage.
There are underlying issues.
Ew, he's like nutting over it.
He's like, oh my god, this guy watched this, uh, five-minute
kiss that we had.
There's like underlying issues that we have in this
marriage.
A fucking singing wouldn't fix this.
Oh my god, we're normal.
We're normal people now.
World's greatest dad.
As me.
We're sure world's greatest mom.
Oh my god, wait, look at our computer.
What?
Who was that on the computer?
We are back in the 90s.
Oh, this is the 90s?
back in the early 2000s that what the fuck look how clear it
is outside where do we live i mean we're on the farm oh i
was like sleeping in a different are you yes you are short
king i don't know just throw it
in the trash
ran away while we're dealing with our problems dear mom and
dad hey what a letter they we didn't even read the letter
dear mom and dad i'm sorry that i did this to you that's
right i know how to make everything good again oh my god
what i have to do is stop fighting i know i'm not a perfect
daughter no wait what i'm sorry i don't like to brush my
teeth Bro, what the fuck is wrong with you?
I'm sorry I don't put my toys where they should be.
I know it's my fault you want to- Whoa!
She's like, oh!
She thinks it's her fault.
And she's right.
No one's actually joking about that.
You should be friends.
Mom and dad are really good friends.
P.S.
They have my pocket money to pay a bus ticket don't worry i
packed a sandwich and a lollipop what the fuck she's gonna
die out there brode what are you do after the bus child
where's our car do we not have a car why what was all that
oil for i'm not gonna talk about it why haven't someone she
already took the bus and we're just running you can go home
no rose honey it's not your fault that we've been fighting
it it isn't no rose when we ignored you when after you try
to call for us for five plus hours it's not your fault we
weren't ignoring you in our house but let's just not me you
can become friends here now honey listen whatever happens
your mom and me rose listen if we're not friends that That
means you get two birthdays and two Christmas
That's fun Okay Come here Oh shit, burn the book Throw that
shit away Burn the book Why the fuck did she bring that shit
with her?
What's wrong with you?
Where did you find this?
I found it at school What?
What?
In a trash can?
There's a reason why it's in the trash.
It's fucking cursed.
It's a cursed book.
How is our kid digging through the trash can in the first
place?
I bet it was you.
I bet you taught her that.
What the fuck?
If your mom had to fight an aggressive squirrel double her
size, what do you think would win?
Mom, of course.
Do we literally fix our marriage?
I think it teaches kids that like, that's unrealistic.
We did it!
I used to think you were completely irrational.
But I have to say, you make more sense now.
We did it!
Oh my god, there's...
The sucker.
Oh my god, and the hammered a weird toolbox.
Yeah.
Oh, there's whoever's fucking binoculars that is.
That was moved at the...
Whoever we're looking...
That's directed at the... our house.
we did it we beat the game look he's she's fixed now see
we're not fucked up parents we fixed her
oh and the clock
oh my god we fucking did it go we did it oh my god there's a
fat b yeah remember that's the one that ditched us yeah that
somehow never got shot why did she put it so high up that's
her god now thank you for fixing the marriage they're
friends again yeah very good friends the book of love
yeah i still can't believe like We got like rave slash what
the fuck did you pause for?
Dude, this is so fucking loud.
I just can't believe we got like the rave club people to be
your audience for a fucking classical music.
That's like the most unrealistic part of this game.
They literally came from a club that was like, go be back in
the club.
God, I'm going to get to you.
Drop the beat.
And now I'm going, ah.
Like, I'm just like, I don't think they were here for this.
They waited in line, dude.
Those people waited in line to get into that club.
And then they fucking got dragged to your fucking classical
music concert.
Like...
Dude, that person's name is Uno Bight.
Uno Bight?
What did I just read?
What?
Uno Bight.
Is there an after-credit scene?
chat yeah they got scammed in the club is there an after
wait this this game was made in europe which country who
made this
frozen two
unreal engine i think it was really creative though this
game was very creative with the mechanics and everything i
love the the I think the level design was really pretty In
general Like I definitely I came into this game really blind
The only thing I remember was like the math And the
beginning Like what they look like Sweden Oh it was made by
the Swedes Oh Oh
I'm surprised like it was You know how like Sweden is like
super fucking was like very cloudy and stuff.
I'm surprised that it was like so sunny out there.
I've never like even looked over yonder.
Is there an after credit scene?
I don't remember.
I didn't check chat.
I don't know.
I was surprised.
I was like, I can see the sun in this game.
What?
Yeah?
There is?
No clue?
Oh, there is!
How do we skip that?
Do we skip it?
No, we can't.
Wait, we can!
Alright, do you want to skip?
Right now.
I have to- Alright, I'm gonna do it.
Wait, I need you to do it.
It's a group effort.
No, there isn't.
We're not supposed to skip!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Oh my god, invite me again, invite me again, invite me again
and just click the credits button.
Is there?
Those credits.
Wait, we have to watch.
Wait, can we just look at the credits here?
Does it work?
No, it doesn't!
Wait, what?
We have to fucking actually...
Oh my god!
How was I supposed to know?
Oh my god, I'm gonna YouTube it.
I'm YouTubing.
Okay.
Alright.
It takes...
It takes two...
You're gonna listen to it.
Ending.
Okay.
Alternate...
After credits...
Credits.
What is it?
The basement.
Yes, there is.
No, there isn't.
There's, like, a basement.
Is this the...
Wait, there isn't?
Were we lied to?
There isn't!
We got...
I can't believe it.
We actually got gas lit.
You just got one guide.
We got one guide.
We got multiple guide.
People were freaking...
out and was like why did you skip why did you skip all right
it's time to go fishing all right ggs goomy are you gonna go
play minecraft or tft i have to tft i'm about to get
eliminated oh shit you're your last place uh they eliminate
like four to five people every day oh shit are your last
place girl what do you mean am i last no you said you might
get eliminated yeah because everyone's climbing right now oh
if i don't climb actively i'll keep dropping because i'm in
the same spot oh all right good luck goomy you want to play
no that's okay good luck bye all right good luck what was
that wait what was the other one chat donkeys said she would
play the other game no there's no other one back there was
no other one that they made No, it just it takes two this
was like it was that you can you can technically they but
they mistaken from two brothers with husband and wife
There's no other game guys guys.
There's no other game Chat I think you guys are like you got
like the oh a way out No, no, no, it's it takes two you guys
80% off right now No, no, no, no, no, that's that's like
made by a fake studio You know, it's like hell divers when
hell divers got released least another studio released hell
divers too to like pretend to be hell divers hell divers too
so people fall for like the 80 off thing that's what they
did for that that's it's not the same studio you say some
yeah yeah yeah yeah
hey have you have you let your chap play um lurk bait yet
lurk bait what yeah lurk bait is that?
It's where you can let your viewers fish.
Wait, what?
Yeah, they can fish on stream.
Oh, I saw this on Twitter before.
Isn't this a Twitch interactive?
Yeah, it's on Twitch only.
Oh, my God, I got Twitch partnered!
Oh, you did?
Yeah, I got Twitch partnered today.
They sent me an email today, being like, congratulations,
you got Twitch partnered!
And like, I sent it an app, but I didn't think I would get
in because, like, I literally only streamed it twice.
And Since I got back and then I got the you'll be like
congratulations You're a twitch partner and I literally
wrote the application because you know, I don't know you
remember but when you write Like why you want to be a twitch
partner.
You have to write like something and all I wrote was please
I just oh my god, please and I submitted it and you say
please No, I don't know.
I think I'm special case here.
I'm pretty sure due to my circumstances They're like, you
know what we know she is
Um, but yeah, I got it today I was so surprised I honestly
didn't think they would give it to me Because usually
they're like You have to be active on Twitch
But yeah The pity part of me That's me Alright, you go You
go Way out Uh, two weeks What?
See you for a way out in two weeks.
What?
We're gonna go from married to brothers.
I mean, it could have been brothers to married.
Yeah, we should have done it the other way around.
Yeah, we should have gotten it the other way around.
That would make more sense.
I mean, we can make up a...
Not make up.
It could be a prequel.
It's our prequel.
Before we were married.
We could be married and then find out we're brothers.
Oh, that's true.
all together yeah we're not telling our kids as long as we
don't tell our child no my friend actually asked me that
story they were like okay let's say you had a boyfriend and
or a husband and then you had a kid together and like
they're the most like perfect person in your entire life
like they're exactly what you want you're so happy with them
they're whatever but then you find out you're and divorce
them and also tell your kids or like, what?
I mean, that's what denial is for.
That's okay.
Okay.
Like, like, that, all right, what will you do?
What will you do?
I have to think about it.
Like, like, it doesn't hurt anybody.
Like, it doesn't hurt anybody.
Well, Maybe the kid, like, genetically-wise, is because of
inbreeding.
But as long as a child doesn't go forth and accidentally,
you know, keep it in the family.
I think...
Yeah, no.
I think at that point...
As long as only...
As long as only, like, two people know, and it's the
parents, I don't think...
like like it's already done like everything's already done
so it's like there's really nothing you you can't take that
away like it's already there the child's there the product
of the inbreeding's there so like if you suddenly split up
you have to explain to the child why that happened i mean i
guess you won't explain it to them until you're at your desk
bed and like the child the reason why the reason why you
have so many problems with your health is because your
father and i are actually related
okay but like and then you die and then you die so you don't
have to live with the guilt because you're already dead as
long you tell them before you they'll have to live with the
trauma after that but you're free you're dead already you
don't have to worry okay wait hold on I I don't quite know
the rules of like Inbreeding and everything so let's say
we're not siblings like what if we're like second cousin
Does it make it's so yeah the genetic trees still yeah as
bad.
It's not as bad.
It's not as bad, but it's still bad No, I'm trying to see
how many like health problems the kid would have you're
trying to find a degree of separation here Like, which is
the right amount of separation?
That would be...
It's okay.
It's bad because you can't have, like, if a population goes
at a certain amount of people, if a population, like, dies
off to a certain amount, there's no way for a population to
continue because at some point, inbreeding is going to
start.
I don't remember what was the minimum, but, like, every,
like, species needs a minimum requirement to prevent
inbreeding.
So it doesn't matter.
It has to be incredibly split off So you don't fuck up the
genetics It's 50, right?
Is it 5?
Because I just want to know how fucked up this kid would be
I mean, eventually, okay, if like, okay, I don't even Why
are we, like, thinking about the degrees here?
Why are we?
I'm thinking scientific.
For what science?
Why would you need this as a science?
curvy I think like I think I was just curious okay, I was
just I was just curious like is it the same like amount of
fucked up genetics if it's like your third like second
cousin Compared to your like brother?
Oh, yeah, because there's less similarities to the genetics.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying the closer the genes are the
more fucked up the byproducts are Because you can have the
genetics to be similar because then there's like like issues
health issues So as long as like so if it's like second
cousin removed or something It's less fucked up than your
fucking brother or sister Okay, because i was just wondering
if it's like Even if it was your second cousin would it be
as fucked up?
Like the kid, it's still fucked.
Okay, the kid.
No, no like the kid is what i'm talking about.
It's so fucked up Morality, like, morality-wise, it's fucked
up no matter what.
By wondering about the kid.
Well, the kid will be less fucked up than the other kids.
Okay, so they're not going to be the same amount of fucked
up.
No, no, because it's all about genetic similarities.
It's about the genes.
But, okay, but yes.
Anyway, I think we've established how fucked up it will be
genetically and morally.
So I guess we can...
So we can move...
You were the one that asked me about this.
Oh, no!
A way out!
It wasn't because I was talking about...
The way out in the brothers' day.
Anyway, guys, I hope you guys had a...
This after...
After game chat got a little bit cursed.
Just a little bit.
But I hope you guys had a great time.
Gumi, you should go play your TFT so you don't get knocked
out.
I felt like I just learned a lot.
Because I actually watched a Tiki Talk recently about...
That one family in America.
What?
The one family in America.
The Inbred family.
What?
The Lanny Kester?
Lanny?
Well, you don't know about the family?
Oh, what?
There was a documentary on them.
The wood takers.
Of odd West Virginia.
Okay, Goomy.
Stop cooking.
Goomy.
I think we gotta move on from the inbreeding.
I think we have to move on.
Anyways, that's why I was so interested in the science
behind it.
Because I watched a documentary about it recently.
Well, by documentary, I meant I watched a TikTok about it.
the tick tocks of movies and videos now.
No, I watched a tick tock about another person who made a
video on them.
I was like, oh!
So this person...
Anyways.
Anyways, GG's goomies.
I can't believe we finished it.
We finally did it.
It took us a while but we fucking did it.
GG's goomies.
Don't get knocked out in TFT.
We're gonna see you two weeks from now.
Bye goomy.
bye bye bye love you all right that was like the most cursed
topic that we've had for a while so uh but we did it guys we
beat it takes two finally the stream one of us the most
streamed games for co-op ever and we fucking finally did it
i hope you guys had a great time watching us um i'm gonna
call it here um how to go to therapy in like three hours we
just finished relation we just finished marriage counseling
and now i have to go to actual therapy later so i'm gonna go
head out now i hope you guys had a great time everybody as
always everyone stay hydrated posture check get up and move
around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for us,
head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.